Time for a quick update on the ministerial statement
made by um. Well,
the Immigration Minister
on January 30th, 2024.
Now this ministerial statement
now gives you the dates to look forward to,
to put on your calendars
to see when what is changing.
Let's take him one by one.
First of all,
the first important day to mention for tomorrow,
which is February 6th, 2024,
is that from tomorrow
the immigration health surcharge is going up by 66%.
So where it was £624 per person per year
is now going to go up to 1000, uh.
And £35 per person per year.
So if you're going for a two and a half years leave
then that is how you will calculate
what you will have to pay.
Now these are the immigration health surcharge payments
for applications made on or after February 6th.
So you still got a few hours,
maybe about six hours
to go ahead and make an application today
if you want to make use of the immigration
health surcharge as it stands today.
Because tomorrow
or midnight onwards
is going to go up.
The other, uh,
date you should remember
or you should know in.
In terms of update with the immigration
is that from January 1st
this is already come in
that dependents are only allowed for students
who are on mighty year
post graduate
research degrees.
Now what the hell does that mean?
Your universities on your uh.
Uh. Your uh. Um.
Colleges will tell you,
but this is
What the Home Office have put down as the marker now.
So if you are a student who wants to bring dependence,
you will only be allowed to bring dependence
if you are on a multi year
postgraduate research degree. Now, uh,
the next date to remember is coming up on March 11th,
because that is the date on which
the care workers will no longer be allowed to bring any
dependents with them.
This is the date where
the home officer put down the marker
where they say that a lot of people are coming here.
So if you are a care worker
and you're coming to the UK on the skilled worker visa,
and you will want to bring your partner,
your children with you
because that is what normal family life means,
that you go together.
But The Home Office thinks that
if you are a care worker,
you do not need to bring your family
because that means there are too many
dependents in the UK
and that they do not want.
So that's the idea behind that. Um,
the next thing
also to remember is
from March 11th, this
care workers will only be able to
sponsored by care providers
that are registered with the Care Quality Commission.
So as I've been talking about this many times,
you might have heard about this many times
from other people of the sources as well,
that there is a lot of abuse of these visas carrying
being carried out Right now,
there are a lot of people who are making sure
that they make a lot of money out of poor people
who want to come as care workers,
who want to have a life of different opportunities.
And they are charging them a leg and a half
and then making sure that they do not even get
any proper rules or proper number of hours.
I get these consultations on a daily basis
where somebody will say,
I came from India,
I came from Africa,
I came from Pakistan, whatever,
and I've not been able to start a job
or do the number of hours that I was promised.
I'm being given one or two hours on a weekly basis,
or maybe one day on a weekly basis,
and that is not enough.
So what do I do?
And the only thing that I can tell them is immediately
look for a different sponsor
where you can actually switch your visa
so that you are
probably working somewhere,
and not just in name.
Because those employers will not suffer,
they will not have any problems.
They've made money out of you.
And once you are no longer able to carry on with them,
or if they decide to shut down,
or if the home office catches them simply,
those employers will be shut down,
those care homes will be shut down,
or those care providers will be shut down.
And you as the applicants or the, uh,
care Workers will be the ones who lose out
because you spent a lot of money to come on that.
And now the Home Office will also look at you as
people who are working in breach
or who are not working
and therefore are in breach of the rules and the.
The permission that you've been granted.
So please be mindful of that.
And if you are in,
uh. Uh. Of, uh.
If you do find yourself in that kind of situation,
please try to get out of it as soon as you can,
because you don't want to have, um,
this kind of a.
A record or this kind of a label against your name
where the Home Office will identify you as a migrant
that fraudulently obtained a job
and came to the UK
and never worked
and tried to get something done here.
So this is how the Home Office will look at you.
I'm just warning you
because this is a huge problem.
From April 4th, 2024,
the skilled worker threshold,
um, uh, for the.
For the salaries
is going up.
Currently it is 26,000 something,
and now it is going to go up to 38,700
from April 4th.
So if you are, uh,
coming over as a skilled worker,
if. As long as you are coming for, um,
you. You coming before this date,
before April 4th, 2024,
you will be able to come on a different salary.
But from April 4th,
your minimum salary
on which you can be sponsored
On a skill work visa
will be £38,700.
Um, except the health and care reason,
which, of course,
we've, uh, uh,
always seen as being exempt from this.
Um, from early April,
the shortage occupations will be gone.
These, if you don't know,
these are the occupations that were given a discount
as far as their salaries were concerned,
because those were in shortfall in the UK.
There were not many people who are able to do those,
so those shortage occupations were given a discount.
But this has now been, uh,
advised by the government
that this should be taken away as well
and nobody should get a discount.
Obviously, when they made the discount
or when they, um,
did the shortage occupations,
there was perfect justification
because we understand
that there is a need for these people
and they are a shortage,
uh, in the UK,
and therefore
we are going to give them a discount
to give them incentives to come.
Now, we still understand
we do not have these people,
we still understand
there is a shortage of these people,
but now our intelligence says
that we should not give them any discounts
or they should be paying the full wages anyway,
whatever it is,
the government knows best.
Um, next is April 11th,
which is the family threshold.
This is where people are most concerned
who are ordinary
British nationals,
ordinary people with indefinite leave,
ordinary people with refugee status,
ordinary people
with limited
leave of Any other kind
that want to bring their spouse
over to the UK,
this is where the income threshold was
currently is
18,600 a year.
Now, granted
this was in 2012
when it started,
but in 2012
this income threshold
was still quite high
according to the, um,
minimum wage requirements
at that time,
but still it was introduced
and now 10, 11,
12 years later,
now we are at this position
where suddenly
that increase
from 18,600
is going to go
quite substantially high.
Um, fortunately for you,
you lucky, lucky people,
the Home Office have decided
and the government have decided
that they are going to do this
in increments.
So they are going to
put the knife in,
but not all of it
at the same time.
So first part goes in
where you are going to go up to £29,000
and that is starting from April 11th.
The next increment will be
a bit later,
which will take it up to 34,500
till finally
they get into, um,
targeting early 2025,
when they say
that this will become the same as the
salary threshold
for the skilled worker
requirement,
which is £38,700.
So if you are currently
in the situation
where you want to bring your spouse over,
please do so.
If you are not able to do so
and you want to do this after
the changes have come in
and you cannot meet the financial
requirements,
that is where things
become a bit difficult
there. Are cases.
There is M M Lebanon, uh,
which has dealt with this before.
There are other cases that will
surely come up as well.
But at this stage,
at this point,
what you need to understand is
if you can meet the financial
requirements.
Fantastic. Otherwise,
if you are in, in care,
if you are in
receipt of carers allowance,
for example,
or you are getting personal
independent payments,
there are a number of exceptions
that are applicable.
If you are not, um. Uh,
if you come within those exceptions,
you will be exempt
from meeting the financial
requirement.
Or if you're not exempt,
you can still make an application.
And there will have to be
an exercise of
a proportionality exercise
at the hands of the judge.
If the matter goes into appeal,
where the Home Office
obviously refuses
your application,
saying that
you cannot meet the financial
requirements,
and then you can go to court
in an appeal
before an immigration judge,
where the immigration
judge will have to see
whether it is
proportional
under the circumstances
that your financial
requirements
not being met,
are keeping a family from being together.
And that is the important factor.
So if you have been
spouses for a long time,
if you have children involved,
if you have
all sorts of history together,
that will become a more
effective, uh, appeal.
And if you do not have a history together,
you just newly married,
you can still
do the application.
You can still
ask for that discretion
to be exercised
or for the judge to look into it.
But as in, when we get there,
we'll talk about that.
That's it for today.
Thank you very much.